una artista de cuentas hace un pequeño
hoyo en la esquina superior de una
cuenta cubica hacia la esquina apuesta
inferior de la cuenta así es que se
trata de una cuenta cubica cada vista de
la cuenta es de medio centímetro cual es
la longitud del hoyo que ella hizo si lo
estoy interpretando adecuadamente déjame
dibujar esa cuenta cúbica que voy a
dibujar como un gran cubo aquí cubos más
bonitos han sido dibujados en la
historia del dibujo de cubos pero voy a
hacer mi mejor esfuerzo veamos este es
mi mejor trabajo en un cubo a mano libre
si este fuera un cubo transparente
podrías ver la parte de atrás así esta
sería la base de este cubo transparente
nos dicen que cada arista de esta cuenta
cúbica le llaman cuenta cúbica nos dicen
que cada arista de esta cuenta cúbica
mide medio centímetro esta de aquí me de
medio centímetro y esta de aquí también
mide medio centímetro y nos dicen que
hizo un pequeño hoyo en la esquina
superior de esa cuenta cúbica hacia la
esquina opuesta inferior de la cuenta de
la esquina superior a la esquina opuesta
inferior me pare
están hablando de la diagonal mayor que
aparece en el cubo yendo de la esquina
superior derecha trasera a la esquina
inferior izquierda delantera ahí aparece
una de las diagonales mayores del cubo
déjame dibujarla aquí esté la distancia
que nos preguntan la longitud del hoyo
que ya hizo esta es la distancia que
necesitamos calcular veamos como podemos
calcular esto y este es un problema
clásico calcular la longitud de la
diagonal mayor de un cubo o en general
de un prisma rectangular y el secreto es
considerar que ésta es la hipotenusa de
un triángulo aunque dicho triángulo aún
no sea obvio para ti para ver que esté
la hipotenusa de un triángulo tenemos
que visualizar primero la diagonal que
se encuentra en la cara inferior esta
diagonal que voy a dibujar aquí
esta diagonal que es la diagonal de la
cara inferior de este cubo si lo ves de
esta manera aquí tenemos un triángulo
rectángulo que atraviesa la mitad del
cubo aquí está el ángulo recto conocemos
este cateto de aquí conocemos esta
distancia si podemos calcular esta
distancia de aquí esta distancia naranja
que corresponde a la diagonal de la cara
inferior del cubo podremos encontrar la
hipotenusa de este triángulo rectángulo
que es la distancia que nos están
preguntando la longitud del hoyo que se
hizo ahora para calcular esta distancia
naranja tenemos que visualizar la base
del cubo hagamos un dibujo si
estuviéramos en la parte superior del
cubo viendo hacia abajo esto se vería
así voy a poner colores en los lados así
va a ser más fácil identificarlos en el
dibujo tenemos este lado de aquí que voy
a poner en azul vamos a dibujarlo aquí
este sería el lado azul este lado de acá
vamos a ponerlo en magenta que se
correspondería a este lado de aquí en
magenta estos dos lados miden igual
miden
por eso lo estoy dibujando
aproximadamente del mismo tamaño y
tenemos este lado naranja que es una de
las diagonales de la base del cubo lo
voy a dibujar con la misma línea
punteada ahí lo tenemos voy a extender
un poco más este lado sabemos que este
es un ángulo recto es un cubo vamos
incluirlo aquí este es el ángulo recto
este lado mide medio centímetro y este
lado de aquí mide medio centímetro
también para calcular esta longitud que
es la diagonal que tenemos aquí vamos a
usar el teorema de pitágoras sabemos que
nuestros catetos miden un medio si
designamos a la hipotenusa por no sé
digamos
x sabemos que el cuadrado de la
hipotenusa es igual a la suma de los
cuadrados de estos catetos
así es que x coa va a ser igual a un
medio al cuadrado más un medio al
cuadrado queremos calcular x así es que
x va a ser igual a la raíz cuadrada de
un medio al cuadrado más un medio al
cuadrado un medio al cuadrado es un
cuarto así es que esto es la raíz
cuadrada de un cuarto más un cuarto
así es que x
es igual a la raíz cuadrada de un cuarto
más un cuarto son dos cuartos o lo que
es lo mismo un medio esto también lo
podemos escribir como 1 sobre la raíz
cuadrada de 2 esto vamos a dejarlo así
por lo pronto así es que esta distancia
de aquí es 1 sobre la raíz cuadrada de 2
que corresponde a esta distancia de aquí
que es 1 sobre la raíz cuadrada de 2
dibujemos ahora este triángulo recto
cuya hipotenusa es la longitud del hoyo
que se hizo en la cuenta
aquí tenemos entonces este de aquí es el
lado largo que tenemos aquí luego este
lado de aquí en amarillo este lado aquí
en amarillo mide un medio y este otro
lado es el que acabamos de calcular aquí
es la equis que calculamos aquí
este lado sería ese que acabamos de
calcular aquí tendríamos entonces el
ángulo recto del triángulo este lado que
hemos calculado que mide 1 sobre raíz
cuadrada de 2 ahora para calcular la
longitud del hoyo podemos aplicar el
teorema de pitágoras nuevamente así es
que si a este lado le llamamos h hd o yo
no mejor vamos a llamarle el de longitud
así que por el teorema de pitágoras
tenemos que l al cuadrado es igual a el
cuadrado de este lado uno sobre raíz de
dos al cuadrado más el cuadrado de este
otro lado que es un medio al cuadrado
así es que más un medio al cuadrado l es
opuesto al ángulo recto de la hipotenusa
y aplicando el teorema de pitágoras el
cuadrado la hipotenusa es igual a la
suma de los cuadrados de los catetos
así es que esto nos queda l al cuadrado
es igual a 1 entre raíz de 2 al cuadrado
que es 1 al cuadrado que es igual a 1
sobre raíz de 2 al cuadrado que es 2
un medio al cuadrado más un medio al
cuadrado que es un cuarto y esto cuánto
nos va a dar un medio más un cuarto
vamos a hacerlo por acá como un
denominador es 4 así es que esto sería
dos cuartos más un cuarto que es igual a
tres cuartos
así es que esto la suma de estos tres
cuartos por lo cual l cuadrada es igual
tres cuartos tres cuartos y de donde
obtenemos que él es sacando raíz
cuadrada a ambos lados de la ecuación l
va a ser igual a la raíz de tres cuartos
o la raíz de tres sobre dos hemos sacado
la raíz de cuatro el denominador que es
igual a 2
así es que él es igual a la raíz de 3
sobre 2 ya lo tenemos la longitud del
hoyo que se hizo de aquí acá hemos
calculado que es igual a la raíz de tres
sobre dos centímetros pues los datos que
nos dieron estaban en centímetros